[Music]
don't blink too fast or you'll miss
four-year-old twins roomie and sir
carter serving next to their mama
beyonce in a new ad for her ivy park by
adidas clothing line for kids and this
makes me proud for the cowboy rodeo
themed campaign bee is seen matching the
twins whom she shares with husband jay-z
in all blue outfits there's even a
moment where we get a rare close-up
glimpse of sir rocking a cowboy hat and
he looks just like big sis blue ivy
speaking of blue she also makes a cameo
strutting fiercely side by side with
queen bee my pride this isn't blue's
first rodeo modeling for ivy park during
bee's previous ivy park collection icy
park the nine-year-old inserted herself
into the shoot and according to her
grandmother tina knowles lawson who
posted about it on instagram blue
totally stole the show is this the
biggest thing you've ever done becoming
a mom this is my greatest
greatest accomplishment and i am the
happiest i've ever been speaking with
harper's bazaar for the magazine's icon
issue cover story beyonce explained how
having her little ones on set with her
during shoots partially inspired her to
create a kid's collection saying quote
on our family vacations we love to
coordinate our outfits my kids are
usually on set with me for shoots and
we'd find ourselves putting them in
extra extra smalls so we could match so
it is a natural progression for ivy park
to introduce a selection of key
silhouettes in children's sizing
[Music]
the ivy park rodeo collection is
available august 19th at adidas.com
ivy park
[Music]